[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de j -p
aujourd'hui jacques une personnalité
yvelinoise qui nous fait le plaisir
d'être présent sur le plateau car elle
sort un nouveau livre alain baraton
bonjour bonjour et merci d'être là
quel plaisir toujours heureux de venir
vous rencontrer converser avec ses
adorables à la barrette ont alors qui
êtes-vous pour ceux qui ne le savent pas
ça m'étonnerait on sait jamais vous êtes
jardinier en chef du domaine national de
versailles et du trianon
oui et puis je suis également
chroniqueur dans une grande radio et la
terre tout à fait là je fonçais un petit
peu de télévision aux côtés de 20,05
eto'o mais ils ont la quotidienne et
puis quand j'ai un petit peu de temps
libre ce qui est relativement rare
j'écris des ouvrages comme celui ci
comme celui-ci qui a le sertit et dont
je suis relativement fuir pendant lien
vous cacher car je pensé un instant que
mon éditeur allait se pendre
je mets un peu beaucoup de temps pour le
rédiger en même temps il est un peu
épais très très très documentaire avec
ses convois travail énorme que j'ai
découvert qu'à parler des avait 500
parcs et jardins sait jamais trop mais
c'est énorme non c'est pas c'est pas
énorme mais chaque arrondissement en a
beaucoup
il ya là des tout petits est l'un des
très gros nyala des très célèbres
d'autres des inconnus je lui envie d'en
parler alors là dorment et jardins de
paris chez grasset vous en avait
répertorié combien aux 180 200 voilà
quand même ah oui oui voila je les ai
tous visiter sans aucune exception
très bien on ne doute pas ça nous change
du dernier livre le cas mais là de ma
mère qui était un livre plus petits
plutôt intimiste qui nous livrer
quelques quelques souvenirs d'enfance
voilà alors là c'est bien dans le public
voilà les jardins publics on étrange
presque toujours dans le vrai rendez
vous c'est je suis fonctionnaire au
ministère de la culture
et je me souviens que lorsque le
ministère fut créé par andré malraux
celui ci avait dit que la culture devait
être à la portée du plus grand nombre
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui j'ai une
certaine je vais dire expertise dans le
monde des jardins et j'avais envie de
faire partager mon expérience des
jardins de paris que sait-on déjà là
pourquoi ce jardin s'appelle-t-il intel
ou ou 1,6 pourquoi avoir voulu créé à
tel endroit un jardin et pourquoi
certains n'ont pas survécu à
l'urbanisation
c'est l'objet de mon livre oui certains
enfin beaucoup épargné
alors moi ce que je voulais savoir c'est
d'abord quand on donne le nom d'une
personnalité un jardin quel est le
symbole alors j'ai un exemple la tour et
s'en est assez triste d'un
malheureusement mais bon ilan halimi ce
jeune homme qui a été tué celle ci
n'étant que les fans juste atroce on lui
a donné son nom a été donné à un jardin
on l'a donnée à merveille je vous donne
un exemple et je reviens sur le jardin
et l'analyse tino rossi était une star
incroyable pour vos parents et vos
grands parents
vous même vous vous souvenez de telles
ressources que vous êtes tout jeune mais
vous avez un autre du pouf petit papa
noël mais il était déjà un petit peu
âgées mais nos grands mères étaient
admiratifs de cet homme qui se
souviendra de tino rossi dans quelques
années
eh bien je me pose quelques questions
avant mais il a un jardin à paris et
tous ceux qui fréquentent le jardin se
souviendront de l'homme qu'il était il y
a un jardin georges brassens qui répudie
permet de se souvenir de ce très grand
compositeur et créateur de chansons et
bien le jardin ilan halimi est un
journal qui est un petit peu comme le
jardin anne frank à paraître sera paix
qui est des gens qui pour leur
confession leur religion leur origine
100 tués dans des conditions ignobles et
ce jardin c'est pas seulement un hommage
qu'on rend à un jeune garçon artix
tragiquement beaucoup trop tôt dans des
conditions épouvantables
nous espérons simplement hommage à
toutes les victimes de l'antisémitisme
c'est ça la rend un hommage tout avec
une manière bien sûr et le jardin c'est
un lieu de liberté un lieu de repos
c'est un lieu de méditation
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui découvrir le
jardin ilan halimi sans avoir une petite
pensée pour ma tous ces actes terribles
que sont les acteurs antisémite d'accord
et c'est aussi un lieu de vie
oui c'est là où la mort quand on donne
le nom d'une personne décédée finalement
on lui donne quelque part une vie
éternelle
est ce que c'est c'est la culture
intellectuelle et la culture physique
que la terre oui et sa vie jund
oui et vous donner le mot juste est un
as mais parfois le nom condamnable que
vous induire en erreur
c'est à dire allons raconter une
anecdote quand j'ai voulu écrire ce
livre
en fait c'est en visitant un jardin le
square de vianney le sportif avait des
tout comprendre
le square du viany est un petit square
juste à côté de notre dame de paris
il est à côté de l'église saint julien
du pot c'est un magnifique square au
milieu d'une merveille que dis-je une
pépite
le plus vieil arbre de paris à robinier
plantes en 1605 là le plus ancien il est
là et il veut toujours et ce soir
viviani portait du moins je le croyais
le nom d'un astronome italien qui
donnaient des noms aux étoiles j'ai
trouvé ça merveilleux mais seigneur oui
ce n'est selon tes erreurs il ne s'agit
pas d'une main viviani celui qui a été
nommé pour europe ça veut dire donner
son nom à ce genre et rené viviani
l'inventeur de l'impôt sur le revenu en
dieu et vous avez commandé alors je me
suis souvent moqué de cet homme est en
fait après j'ai compris pourquoi il
avait créé l'impôt sur revenu ont ils
avaient malheureusement raison c'est la
guerre de 14 18 qui justifie un effort
national mais comme quoi le nom d'avant
aussi parfois induire en erreur les
joueurs on veut dire sur ce que vous
disiez qui est important sur la vie il
ya un jarret qui s'appelle le jardin
anne frank est bien dans ce jardin
pousse un marronnier qui est directement
issu du fruit produit par le marronnier
le vrai que anne franck louvrier de ses
fenêtres de la maison
eh bien oui bien sûr donc quand vous
parlez de fautes d'éternité et donnons
la véraison
le jeune anne frank ont une parfaite
illustration la couenne aller chercher
un marrant dumargne hollandais oui pour
le planter là on verra bien alors à
petit et mais maintenant bien ce
marronnier est le témoin de la
souffrance de cette gamine le témoin de
sa déportation et là encore le témoin de
toute la cruauté humaine
d'accord mais c'est gai tout ça mais
n'empêche qu'on a prononcées importante
alors c'est triste bien sûr l'avis de
ilan halimi la vie de dingue c'est une
tragédie c'est un cauchemar
mais il ne faut pas oublier il ne faut
pas oublier d'où l'importance que les
gens là contribuent à l'entretien de la
mémoire exactement voilà et c'est aussi
une façon aussi d'honorer les personnes
tuées au pouvoir
et puis il se rappelait plein de choses
le jardin casque d'or par exemple on
apprend des trucs incroyables ces
banques le film se souvient du côté des
choses vos yeux pétillent
parce que vous savez que le jardin c'est
aussi un lieu pour l'enfance on a tous
un mémoire en mémoire quand on est
enfant un jardin où l'on a compris mais
une main mon un grand-père le jardin une
basse et le bassin neptune vous imaginez
tout ce qu'ils ont vécu à paris puis se
souvient leurs premiers pas au square
des batignolles dans le jardin des
tuileries au luxembourg sont des lieux
merveilleux le jardin c'est aussi un
lieu de découvertes de rencontres qui
n'a pas espérer un baiser sur un beau
rendez vous amoureux
évidemment le jardin vous accompagne
tout au long de votre vie aujourd'hui le
jardin est devenu en période d'après
confinement remarquerez le lieu où l'on
peut déjeuner tranquillement sur un banc
en respectant les visites naïf
d'où l'importance d'avoir ouvert les
jardins après oui un peu tardivement je
trouve à mes yeux
et puis le jardin c'est aussi le lieu de
la méditation
vous êtes devenu et je vous le souhaite
un jour une très vieille dame et le plus
loin le plus loin possible
eh bien vous aurez besoin peut-être de
réfléchir sur votre vie sur vos amours
sur votre vie en général eh bien vous
verrez que un banc ou un fauteuil
un arbre un jardin c'est l'endroit idéal
pour se souvenir et que disait cicéron
on est des êtres amis oui oui parce que
j'adore les hommes utilisent le même
vocabulaire que moi et qui sont capables
en deux mots de résumer une grille ce
seront des aigles ont fait dans la vie
il faut deux choses un jardin et une
bibliothèque
elle va bien cette fa lun oui j'aime
beaucoup ce que j'ai la chance d'avoir
un jeu c'est un retard et jocelyne
publiera ce sens que nous devons nous
transmettre vous avez vous vous êtes
passionné vers ce micro parce que vous
avez le besoin de communiquer et de
transmettre ce que vous aimeriez
communiqué je fais la même chose moi
j'en veux andré le nôtre veut c'est le
grand patron de versailles un homme que
des cd déjà la magnifique mais excepté
de son oeuvre
il n'a pas laissé d'écrits de créer deux
d'école n'a pas formé d'apporter et je
l'on voudrait hammam général
mais j'étais en australie mais oui parce
que justement on a le devoir de
communiquer nous parlions de
l'antisémitisme et du racisme
croyez vous vraiment que ce que nous
transmettions davantage de notre sahara
cette bêtise circulant encore autant je
ne crois pas il faut transmettre
d'accord sur ces belles paroles et again
polémiquant actuellement au à propos du
cinéma la pagode du jardin du cinéma la
pagode est ce qu'il en est exactement
c'est un bâtiment on va les images nous
sommes cela est perçu à ce qui est
triste c'est que lorsque jacques lang
était ministre de la culture il avait
classé le bâtiment et le jardin
monuments historiques et qu'on restaure
le bâtiment est que pour favoriser la
raison de ce bâtiment
une histoire incroyable on a coupé les
arbres quand arrêtera-t-on de couper les
uns pourquoi est comme il est parce que
sous couvert de restauration je crois
que les armes déranger les feux
je sais pas à quel point les hameçons
sont gênants mais on il ya le besoin
souvent de les couper dans le cas de la
restauration
je suis navré on doit être capable de
restaurer et 20 juin godbillot bas qui
était merveilleux
ça y est le mal est fait les absents
partait 21 que l'on arrêtera une bonne
fois pour toutes de massacrer les
végétaux on doit quand même être
capables va je ne sais pas quand on a
une statue dans un jardin on préserve la
statue on ne va pas la détruire
pourquoi systématiquement détruire les
végétaux il y avait quelques végétaux
intéressant dans ce jardin et je déplore
qu'on les ait coupés d'accord donc c'est
trop tard malheureusement oui bon ok
dites moi depuis le confinement
enfin le confinement au château comment
ça s'est passé est ce qu on a vu des
choses qu'on voyait pas avant a le
confinement à verser pour ceux qui comme
moi ont été je vais dire à ce train est
resté pour y travailler
on ya découvert des choses
extraordinaires un parc qui retrouve la
liberté et qui laisse apparaître des
fleurs sauvages qui croient y arriver
des choses que vous ne voyez pas avant 8
quantité de petites fleurs que nous
avons répertorié un lien mais les
tondeuses étaient elles aussi fini donc
la nature que s'exprimer on a vu des
animaux prendre possession des lieux
les renards
si vous regardez de manière éhontée les
mythes provocation en danger chez moi
que fais tu ici nous avons vu des
renardeaux des oies qui ont fait leur
petit dessine autour du grand canal le
parc a retrouvé la quiétude et puis
surtout ce qui était merveilleux à
versailles et partout ailleurs
c'était ce silence se calme ce côté
paisible enfin avait pas d'avion
au-dessus de la tête et pas de bruit la
nature semblait reprendre ses droits
j'en profite pour un petit allez-y
cantonnait pas c'est toujours pas ça a
été l'occasion forcément plus que
j'aurais aimé par contre c'est que
justement on tienne compte du
confinement ont pour réfléchir sur le
futur parce qu'on est en larmes on nous
sommes en train d'aller droit dans la
catastrophe écologique
le confinement a prouvé qu'on était
capable d'arrêter de trop consommer trop
voyager son essayons d'obtenir jamais
content de ce continent pour évoluer
positivement des croyants non non non
ces bonnes paroles
bon moi ce que ce 2 à quoi je crois ce
sont les jardins partagés
pour ceux qui n'ont pas eu la chance
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin d'avoir un
jardin
jean-paul faisant parler et sauf que
cevital justement par rapport au
confinement où les gens sont restés
vraiment coincé dans des petits mètres
carrés urbain c'est la seule les gens là
partagé la vie ça armes étaient des
femmes et des hommes de tout âges de
toutes conditions de toutes origines
vous mettez une femme née en algérie un
homme né en afrique noire
un français de biens bien née à paris
vous l'aimez claude et ils sont dans un
même jardin il cultive il part et
l'amitié n'est je constate que toi
plaisir de grands mouvements dans les
banlieues des difficiles les espaces
verts sont rarement dommage et je crois
que le jardin est peut-être un lieu
d'unification et des métiers le banc
j'adore parler du banc le banc qui est
le premier réseau social ya un type qui
ajoute un type ou une femme a eu l'idée
de créer un meuble qui permet à
plusieurs fessier de s'asseoir côte à
côte et bien que vous mettez des gens de
toutes les couleurs côte à côte sur le
même banc et qui discute c'est peut-être
le début de la fin du racisme de
l'antisémitisme
en un mot de toutes ces bêtises que nous
pourrissent la vie et qui n'ont plus
leur place aujourd'hui
bon en tout cas en attendant on reste
régaler cet été avec ce merveilleux
ivre vous êtes allé hors des sentiers
battus fort de vaux sentiers battus
puisque vous êtes allé dans tout paris
où les jeunes travaillent mais jean
lannes versailles pour autant non mais
bon on a les droits on a le droit
d'aller et donc changement d'herbage je
vous le vous voilà un dicton jeu dicton
bon bref vous êtes allé partout nous
fait découvrir des pépites et plein
d'histoires incroyables et merci
beaucoup et à très vite alors sur france
inter sur france 5
peut-être un nouveau livre qui s'est
abattue depuis j'y suis je vous en
parlerai la prochaine fois bon promis
elles font moins vite et avec joie bon
merci beaucoup à la baratte on a bientôt
a très vite mené t
[Musique]